في شهر مارس هذا،
على بعد 120 ميلًا من باغوسيان موسكو، ثم
توقف فجأة واستدار بعد ظهر
الأمس ماذا حدث لماذا
أه دونا ليس لدينا
معلومات كاملة بوضوح ومن السابق لأوانه
معرفة إلى أين سيتجه هذا الأمر بالضبط
وأظن أن هذا أمر مؤثر
الصورة ولم نر الفصل الأخير
بعد ولكن يمكننا أن نقول هذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء،
ما رأيناه هو أمر غير عادي
وأعتقد أنك رأيت شقوقًا تظهر
لم تكن موجودة من قبل أولاً في
وجود باغوسيان المرتفع في الأمام والوسط
التشكيك في أسس
العدوان الروسي على أوكرانيا
لتبدأ أه الحجة القائلة بأن
أوكرانيا أو الناتو بطريقة أو بأخرى يشكلان تهديدًا
لروسيا وتحديًا مباشرًا لبوتين
نفسه
لذا فكر في الأمر بهذه الطريقة
قبل 16 شهرًا
كانت القوات الروسية على عتبة الباب  في
كييف، اعتقدت أوكرانيا أنهم سوف
يستولون على المدينة في غضون أيام، ومحو
البلاد من الخريطة، والآن يتعين عليهم
التركيز على الدفاع عن
العاصمة الروسية موسكو ضد المرتزقة من
صنع بوتين، لذا فإن هذا يثير الكثير
من الأسئلة العميقة التي سيتم
الإجابة عليها  أعتقد أنه في الأيام والأسابيع
المقبلة، هل تعتقد أن هذه هي
بداية النهاية لفلاديمير بوتين؟
لا أريد أن أتكهن بأن
هذه مسألة داخلية في المقام الأول
بالنسبة لروسيا، ما رأيناه هو هذا
على الرغم من أننا  لقد رأينا هذا العدوان
على أوكرانيا يتحول إلى
فشل استراتيجي في جميع المجالات، روسيا
أضعف اقتصاديًا وعسكريًا، لقد
تراجعت مكانتها في جميع أنحاء العالم،
وتمكنت من إبعاد الأوروبيين عن
الطاقة الروسية، وتمكنت من توحيد
وتعزيز الناتو بأعضاء جدد
وتحالف أقوى.  لقد تمكنت من
الانفصال عن روسيا وتوحيد
أوكرانيا بطرق لم تحدث
من قبل. هذا مجرد فصل إضافي
لكتاب سيء للغاية كتبه بوتين
لروسيا ولكن ما
يلفت النظر في هذا الأمر هو أنه داخلي
وحقيقة أن لديك من  داخل شخص
يشكك بشكل مباشر في سلطة بوتين،
ويشكك بشكل مباشر في الأسس التي
قام عليها هذا العدوان
ضد أوكرانيا، وهو في حد ذاته
شيء قوي للغاية، فهو يضيف
شقوقًا حيث يذهب هؤلاء عندما يصلون إلى
هناك مبكرًا جدًا لقوله، لكنه
يثير بوضوح أسئلة جديدة  على بوتين أن
يتعامل معك،
تحدثت عن أوكرانيا بالطبع
شنت أوكرانيا هجمات مضادة متزامنة
ضد عدة جبهات روسية
بينما كان كل هذا يحدث، ما هو
فهمك لآخر ما حدث على
الأرض في أوكرانيا وهل سيتمكنون من
الاستفادة من الفوضى؟  في
ساحة المعركة، ما مدى ميل الولايات المتحدة
وحلفاء الولايات المتحدة في حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) إلى الفوضى من
أجل الاستفادة،
لذا فهذه هي الأيام الأولى
للهجوم المضاد الذي سيستمر
على مدى أسابيع وربما حتى على مدار أشهر، حيث
يمتلك الأوكرانيون ما يفعلونه
إنهم بحاجة إلى أن يكونوا ناجحين، إنها
صعبة، إنها أرض صعبة، لقد
وضع الروس الكثير من
الدفاعات على مدى الأشهر الماضية
تحسبًا لهذا الهجوم المضاد،
لكنه يتقدم وإلى الحد
الذي أصبحت فيه روسيا مشتتة الآن،
يجب على بوتين أن يقلق  حول ما يحدث
داخل روسيا بقدر ما يجب عليه
القلق بشأن ما يحاول فعله بشكل غير
ناجح في أوكرانيا، أعتقد أن هذا
يخلق ميزة إضافية
للأوكرانيين للاستفادة منها، ولكن
بغض النظر عن أنهم يضغطون للأمام، فإن
لديهم خطة واضحة  'نتابع
ذلك